alright guys my name is George I'll talk
a little bit about my career path for a
moment but I just want to was thinking
what am I going to talk about because
acetyls you in five minutes
so I thought what four things that I
really struggled to grass grass with in
my first two years of teaching and the
first one was organization I had no idea
how to organize my resources when I
first started teaching so I'm just
sharing something that seems to work
reasonably well for me over the last
couple of years so basically what I did
was this in here put them on mathematics
documents and here I have the old course
the old mathematic syllabus which ends
this you you thin that I have my stage
boring Stage five bulbs set up plus
around your text etc you think that will
have all my syllabus areas like number
and then again within there I have
[ __ ] slow fractions every possible
worksheet like the one moves and they're
illegal so that way when I sit in there
because every class is different and I
don't teach the same way every sin we've
I cannot because I have these four
different group of groups of kids so
everything is in there and I just go
through it when I go to start teaching
the topic when I start using the
resources other one of the resources I
like to use and again try to find a way
that works for you keep it electronic
within my recommendation but just
organize it the way you teach a number
and try me really logical the way it
works as well that way you can find your
stuff later on so that was the first
thing my struggling with and spent most
of my thirsty grass uniqueness Carol
organized everything
the second thing get involved I can sort
of recommend enough be like there's
first-year teachers or as teachers to a
neutral system to actually been involved
with different issues within your school
so basically one of the things I didn't
clean my first year of teaching was
become did you see when you receive
we want to have a massive push floor so
as I was a younger teacher and someone
who sort of really wanted to get
involved in is very excited with it we
start off doing logic puzzles within
morning roll call or morning pastoral
care or whatever you want to call it and
basically every day could be a different
puzzle in there in the morning messages
and the kids would go through and
actually go ahead and answer it if
you're boxing this sort of McDuck's like
the stockroom where they'd come and
they'd drop off their answers so try and
get involved with your school you guys
have got so many fresh ideas that Matt's
coordinators one security out okay we
want to know about them please don't sit
there and just keep them to yourself
till you or maybe I'd really like to run
this initiative during this week and
this is what I want to give a shot and
do it don't just sit there and say I'll
do it later I'll do it later and that's
what I want to hear about it but
sometimes they might not have that sort
of that vision to sort of bring the
fresh ideas that we have so please bring
to your school the fresh ideas that you
have we want to hear about them we want
to have a look at how we can better our
departments with you guys
third one okay plan and share your gun
lessons you guys really do have some
outstanding ideas and some outstanding
listening to be want to hear about one
of the ones that I've used and I wanna
share with you boys was one just around
the fifa world cup and it's basically
the idea was I was getting really
annoyed them to watch the soccer games
and little hours of the night so I can't
pay me to the kids is there a better way
of organising schedule and the kids
basically have to develop a schedule for
two groups associating with a certain
number of rules okay so I put the rules
that these rules were from FIFA but so
that it was an appropriate time that the
players are playing in the country that
were playing and for the viewing
audiences and this is an activity I'll
use with international time and time
zones which again extends the kids I've
used it with more capable kids or when
the World Cups on just to sort of engage
discs
so again share your gun lessons with
everyone okay yes they're yours you'll
get credit for but share them you're
going to
profession and the fourth thing don't
jump the gun be career wise I think
there are many outstanding mathematics
teachers especially graduates from here
that I've seen come through a lot of the
time people are going to say I think you
mean perfect this position go apply for
a coordinators position now and you'll
have people tapping you on the shoulder
as you get through sometimes it's a good
step but other times it's what they want
for you but not necessarily what do you
want think about what it is that you
want to achieve think about it what
schools it is that you want to work in
think about the clients feel that you
want to work with and apply for
positions then don't just sit there and
jump guns because people are telling you
already make sure you're ready to take
on the overall responsibility of
mathematics and in most cases newsy of
the school that you're going to be
involved and if you're going to look at
you know all the labor so